- [Narrator] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat techno music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History,
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is Alexandra Horowitz,
who is an Adjunct Associate
Professor of Psychology
at Barnard College, Columbia University.
She's the author of On Looking,
Eleven Walks with Expert Eyes,
and Inside of a Dog, What
Dogs See, Smell, and Know.
Alexandra, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thanks, Harry.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Philadelphia,
and I mostly grew up in Colorado.
My father moved out to Colorado,
and so I was a quasi-westerner early on.
- And looking back, how did your parents
influence your thinking about the world?
- Oh a lot.
Both my parents were trained as attorneys,
my dad still practices.
And I think they have a
very analytical approach
to problem solving, to thinking.
That was instilled in me
from a pretty early age.
- And what was the conversation like
at the dinner table, about world events,
about science, about what?
Or about the law?
- Well in some ways,
sometimes it was about the law
actually, we talked about
the law a fair amount.
And that was pretty intriguing,
'cause there's the process
and I was interested
in understanding the process,
and seeing that you could
come to an end of a process.
But also just about ordinary things.
What happened in the day,
and really analyzing what
happened in our days,
or social interaction, or,
you know not just reporting
but also kind of
ruminating on what it was.
So we could have a long conversation about
a one little incident that happened
at the grocery store, at school,
or walking the dog.
- And when did you acquire your first dog,
if acquire is the right word?
- I know, ownership is a
broad question. (laughs)
- So when--
- At that time we were
all owners though, right?
- Yeah, yes, yeah.
- And our family lived with dogs
as long as I remember,
I think from the time I was very young
we had a dog.
My first dog I remember was
maybe a dog named Heidi,
when I was six.
And then I grew up with a dog,
and even in college, I maybe
had a year or two in college
where I didn't live with a dog,
and then I had dogs in college.
So I actually have always lived with dogs.
- When you were younger
and the family had a dog,
did you find yourself observing them?
Were you a scientist in
becoming at that point,
or was it just the
friendship relationship?
- I don't think I, I don't remember being
scientific in my approach
to the dog at all.
I think what I had was a
sensitivity to animals,
and plants actually, I think
I was just kind of worried
about their experience, or
what was happening with them.
Not to say I couldn't forget,
I wasn't that sensitive a kid.
But I wasn't analyzing them.
I just wanted to be assured
of their well being.
And that I can remember
from a very early age.
- Mm-hmm, and so when did,
what were your first
steps towards science?
Was that when you went to college?
Or even before then?
- I had interest in science,
but not behavioral science exactly.
You know, I was very
interested in physics.
Again, I liked the iterative process
that led to a result.
So that's very satisfying in math
and in science as a
secondary school student.
In college I got very
interested in philosophy,
and it actually diverted me
from science a little bit,
but was ultimately I think
frustrating for that reason,
wanting to come to a kind of end point,
or at least periotic tentative end points
that science allows you
to progress through.
So it wasn't until after I earned my BA
and I was working, and
away from academics,
that I started thinking that
I'd like to know more about
some of these topics that
I had just forgotten about.
You know, in pursuing philosophy
in particular cognition,
so that's when I started taking classes
and I wound up applying to a PhD program.
- Mm-hmm, and where did you do your PhD?
- At University of California San Diego
in the Cognitive Science Department.
- And that, so you're a
cognitive psychologist,
but are you also a zoologist, or?
- Well you could almost say that.
I mean in a way you get to be a little bit
of a jack of all trades
as a cognitive scientist
because the field itself was formed
by philosophers, and psychologists,
and neuroscientists, and anthropologists,
and computer scientists
who were all realizing
that they were asking similar questions,
just approaching it a different way.
Artificial intelligence wants
to know about the brain,
and neuroscientists want to know
whether the ideas of the brain
could be mapped, programmed,
and then there are observers of behavior,
and testers of behavior and so forth.
So from that position,
I could be called any one of
those things a little bit.
I've never been called a neuroscientist
or computer scientist but,
I started studying animal behavior
and became a little bit
of what I would call
a cognitive ethologist, right.
Somebody who's looking at
animal behavior naturally,
and observing, and then trying to make
inferences about cognition.
- Mm-hmm, and at San Diego were there any
particular people that you worked with?
Who did you do your dissertation on,
and then how did you come
to this focus on dogs?
- I came to the focus on dogs
a little bit accidentally,
so I did start to get
interested in animal cognition,
and what kind of inferences
we can make about
non-human animal minds.
And I was doing research with people who
were studying the cognitive
behavior of animals,
the bonobos for instance,
or the social behavior of animals.
I joined a rhinoceros
observation research project
at the Wild Animal Park
under Ron Swaysgood.
But then I got interested in dogs
because I was interested
in the topic of play
as a natural behavior,
which is so interesting
in human development,
and what might let us see something
that allow us to make some inference
about what the dogs understand or no.
And so you'd look for a playing animal,
and nobody I knew there
was studying an animal
who was playing all the time.
You know you could go
and watch the bonobos
and they'd play once in a while,
and then they'd go off in the private area
of the enclosure and they'd play
and you don't see them.
But I realized I was watching
play three times a day.
You know I had a dog and
I would watch him play.
And so I got interested in studying dogs
and there was no one studying dogs
at UC San Diego, at least not in this way.
But Mark Beckoff, who was
at UC Boulder in Colorado,
had studied dogs as a
biologist for a long time.
And I got in touch with him,
and really learned distance from him
how to look at dog behavior,
and then at UC San Diego, Shirley Strum
in the Anthropology Department,
who studies baboons,
took me under her wing
to help me refine my
ethology technique, and Jeff Elman,
who was just somebody
who could do anything,
a kind of renaissance intellect
in the Cognitive Science Department,
took me on intellectually.
So I had these, a distant
mentor in Mark Beckoff,
and Shirley Strum and Jeff
Elman were my committee chairs.
- Well I can't help but ask you this.
Do you think there was a bias against dogs
in the sense that no one,
at least at San Diego,
had taken in the sense that
we sort of take them for granted?
- Oh yeah, oh for sure.
There was a huge bias against dogs,
and I shared that bias against dogs.
When I thought about it,
or somebody might have proposed to me,
"Maybe you could study
dogs, they're playing."
And I really scoffed at the idea.
First of all, if you were interested
in non-human animal minds
you were gonna be looking
at a primate probably.
Because what, non-human
primates are gonna be
the most connected to us.
And so therefore the ones that have
the interesting answers to
the questions you wanna ask.
And dogs are so familiar.
I think, I've tried to think
back on why it could be
that dogs were rejected
as a cognitive subject
in 1996 or something,
and I think it was just we already had
this vocabulary to talk about dogs.
And so no one was studying dogs.
I remember a well-known
primatologist coming
and visiting campus,
and I had just started
to observe dogs, and I said,
gee, I think there's really something,
this might've been 1998.
There's something really interesting here,
and what do you think about this?
And he really laughed at that idea.
And now he and many
others are studying dogs.
It's really exploded as an
interesting research topic.
And I think a lot of
people had that realization
right at the same time in
different parts of the world.
There's a big group in
Hungary, for instance,
that was studying dogs.
- And is it the case that,
I mean, I don't think your
research has gone there yet but
that dogs in a way in
our closeness to dogs
could tell us really something
about humans basically,
in the sense that the
interaction between the two,
dogs and humans.
- Certainly, yeah, insofar as
they are in many ways
reflecting the process
of our ancestors for
some thousands of years.
They reflect our selection of them, right?
We might've chosen and decided to breed,
intentionally or not,
those animals that had traits
that were most familiar, or pleasing,
or recognizable, you know,
reflected us, mirrored us in some way.
And so they're a demonstration of
what we think is important in a companion
in some ways,
and I think that makes them
good companion animals,
and such easy companion animals.
So there is a lot of
interesting research, I think,
which is comparative in that sense.
I'm more interested in a dog qua-dog,
but yeah, they reflect
back on us, certainly.
- Have you ever thought of a comparison
between dogs and cats basically,
in the sense that they're very different.
- As domesticated creatures, right?
- Yeah, as domesticated creatures, yeah.
- Right, and the selection process
must've been much different for cats.
And that's because maybe you're starting
with a really different species
that doesn't have the
same kind of sociality
and interactions in their groups
as the proto-dog or
ancestor wolf did in theirs.
But also they're much less
willing subjects, cats.
(laughing)
So that's probably limited.
There's probably a bias
against cat cognition research
because the cats you know,
just won't walk into
the laboratory with you.
- So what did you wind up doing
your dissertation on then?
- I did it on the behaviors
of theory of mind,
this meta-cognitive concept
that we apply to humans,
and a kind of case study of dogs at play.
So dyadic interactions between
dogs, rough and tumble play.
So I was assessing that play behavior
and seeing if there was
anything that looked like
it was a precursor to or rudimentary
understanding of other's minds.
- Others being--
- Dogs.
- Dogs, yeah, other dogs.
- Other dogs.
- I like to ask my guests what they see
as the skills involved in what you do,
and how do you train to
acquire those skills?
- I think for my research
it's mostly about
patience and observation.
A lot of my research
has to do with watching.
And somehow that's a
kind of attention skill
that we don't develop that much
in normal schooling, I think.
Not just seeing, but really observing.
And one way that's easier to do that
is observing through video playback.
So you videotape a lot of
episodes of a behavior,
and you watch it in slow motion,
and you start seeing
something different happening.
And so that's where
patience really comes in.
I mean watching dogs play is great fun,
but the science of it only happens
when you're watching a 30th
of a second of it at a time
of that video playback,
which is extremely tedious
in writing sequential behaviors down so,
a 30 second playback might
take hours to code effectively.
And so you have to be
interested in observation,
and then you have to be very
patient to deconstruct it.
- When you say code,
explain to our audience
what you mean by that.
- So any behavior, any
anthropologist or ethologist
would be interested in finding out
the parts of that behavior.
We might say, an interview
is happening here
but what constitutes that interview.
And there are various levels
at which you could describe
this behavior that's happening between us.
And we choose some level,
and we're not interested
in finger movements
or limb extensions,
but instead maybe we're
interested in the conversation.
And a code would be
making a representation
such that you could look
at lots of different
instances of conversations
and if there are
patterns that are similar
across those coded behaviors.
- And in the case of a dog who
when you come to the study of the dog,
there isn't an enormous literature
that this breakdown becomes,
there's just an awful lot going on,
that it's only through this kind of
careful observation that you can see that.
- Right, I think we see play for instance,
in dogs as a unitary behavior.
It's just, they're playing,
then that's kind of the
end of the assessment
of what's happening.
But you could break it down
into smaller components,
you could look at how they're using
each other's attention
when they're communicating.
You could look at dominance,
missive behaviors,
lots of ways you could do it.
And I used an ethogram,
a list of behaviors
to code the behaviors I was looking at
from Mark Beckoff and other people
who had studied dog behavior.
And also from people who'd
studied other animal behaviors.
So ethologists all use each
others ethograms to get ideas
about what are the kinds of behaviors
we might see in this animal.
And now there are pretty exhaustive lists
of ethograms of different
animal's behaviors.
- So in a way it becomes like
reading encrypted
conversations between humans.
In other words, once you
break the encryption,
there's a whole conversation going on,
whether between dogs or
between dogs and humans.
- Right, that make the
conversation work, right,
or that make the play work,
the constituent elements.
Now your analogy only
breaks down insofar as
that doesn't mean we suddenly understand
it's meaning all the time,
but we certainly have analyzed
it at a different level.
And so we might have gained
another appreciation for
for instance, how dogs
use turn taking in play,
even if we don't understand play.
- And so you're really
exposing the complexity,
which might be an entry
point to other complexities
in the relationship of dogs to each other.
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean
I got interested in play
because it's a context
in which it's possible.
In humans we learn a lot
of understanding of others,
so by playing with this
real, pretend distinction
early in childhood, we
might start realizing oh,
there's more than one way to view this
banana I'm holding up to my ear.
It's not just a banana,
but it's also a phone.
And then oh, that person in front of me
might not know the things I do,
they know something else.
That seems to be part of that development.
So one wonders if one looks
at play in other species
if they're also based on an understanding
that the dogs would use in other context,
which is of another animal's perspective.
That they know, or believe,
or think different things
than that dog believes.
- What are their qualities of
temperament besides patient?
It sounds like there's
a lot of empathy really.
Is that--?
- For me that definitely was a grounding
for my interest in
looking at animals, right,
and I think that's probably the case
for a lot of other animal
behavior researchers.
And a real sense of connection
with a non-human animal
of any kind, and an interest,
a curiosity about other animals.
And desire to not just
have a simple answer
as to what the animal is doing,
what the animal is feeling,
but to really analyze their behavior
before jumping to any conclusion.
- Now what was your goal in writing
The Inside of the Dog?
Obviously in part it was
reporting on your research,
but beyond that were there
other goals involved here?
- You know I was then a dog researcher,
I had gotten interested
in the dog as the dog,
as opposed to just this
theory of mind entry
into non-human animal minds.
And I lived with dogs,
and one of my interests
was in that tension,
being a scientist of dogs
and also an owner or liver with dogs.
And how we have two
different approaches to dogs.
So I was wearing two
different hats all the time.
You know the ways you deal
with the dog in your house,
and the ways we looked
at dogs analytically,
and an interest to bring
the latter to the former.
Not just for me but for other owners,
and saying, ah, these are
questions we form about our dogs.
What do they know?
What are they thinking?
What do they understand?
What do they think of me,
people would always ask me,
"What does my dog think of me?"
And is there anything I
could bring from my approach
or my results or the other dog
researchers results to date
which would bear on those questions.
So it's realizing that
there's a universe of people
who live with dogs who
have questions about them,
and that now there's this science
that wasn't that well
reported on at that point,
which would be fascinating to them.
- What is, in your work, what
does creativity look like?
I mean can you tell us
about an ah-ha moment
where you suddenly came on something
that was really surprising for you
in the area of play?
- Well it was, I guess I
have a couple possibilities
that leap to my mind.
One was even finding out
about the possibility of dogs
as a cognitive subject,
and that happened through
reading Mark Beckoff
and Collin Allen's book, Species of Mind.
And I distinctly remember Mark,
who was studying the
behavior of dogs in play,
made a suggestion that
maybe there's something
about shared intentionality,
understanding of intentionality
in these play bows that
they do, the play signals,
which seemed to be something
like a request for play,
or an announcement that
I'm about to play with you,
and perceive play, and
continue throughout play,
and are very important for play.
And so he just made the suggestion
that there was something
meta-cognitive basically,
about the dog's very simple act
of going down on their front legs
with the rump high in the
air, wagging their tail.
And that was, that moment
was really inspiring
'cause I was very interested
in the meta-cognitive aspects,
or possibilities in
non-human animal minds.
You know, are they
thinking about thinking,
are they think about other's thinking?
And here was somebody saying
a very simple behavior,
if you looked at the context,
might be connected to that.
So I thought, whoa,
I've gotta look at that.
And that's really what I then spent
two years of research looking at.
So that was a big moment.
And I also think before I
started writing this book
and I got interested in more of how
the science could elucidate
the experience of the dog,
I was reading other
biologists and came across
Jakob von Uexkull who was influential
in some areas of animal behavior research,
but had kind of fallen out
of the popular literature,
he wasn't really in favor
I guess, 20 years ago
in animal behavior research.
You didn't really hear his name a lot.
But he had this idea,
the umwelt of the animal,
that you could imagine the world view,
the soap bubble in which
any animal existed,
defined by the things that
are important or salient
in their environment, in
their own sensory capacity,
and that really tickled me.
I realized he's telling me how to find out
what the experience of the dog is,
which is figure out what's
important in their environment
from their point of view,
watch their behavior to do that,
and understand their senses,
and therefore get a different picture
of what they experience in
a space, and we can do that.
And so that was a big moment too.
And that's still very
influential in my thinking
about how to research dog behavior.
- In a way that sort of defines
the agenda for your book,
and I wanna walk you through your book,
and you really identify three broad areas
that you wanna look at.
State what those are,
and then I'll walk you
through each of them.
- The sensory areas?
Well, olfaction, that's
a huge sensory area.
There's a visual area,
and who's gonna be in their visual space,
and I'm not sure what the third area--
- Well I guess what I
meant was the overall
framework of the book,
so it's looking at the dog's origins,
it's sensibilities--
- then their senses.
- Yeah, then their senses,
and then their interactions with humans.
- That's true, all right
so right, absolutely.
- That's how I saw the book.
- That's great.
Well you know, everybody
reads it a different way.
That is all in there.
Right, so where does this dog come from,
who is the dog, and then what
are their sensory capacities,
perceptual experiences, and then humans,
and what do they see of us,
and how have we influenced their biology,
and the interaction and bond.
- So let's begin with the origins.
They come, their origins
are in the family of wolves,
I guess you could say,
but we don't think about having a wolf
in our house these days.
- And I don't think there's
any atavistic possibility
that the dog is going to
become the wolf again.
- Right, right, maybe on television,
but we'll leave that aside.
But so what, talk a little about that,
because as I read your book,
what you're saying basically is
it drew some positive things
from coming from that line.
But on the other hand,
there were major changes in its evolution.
So what is it about a wolf
that could be the
starting point for a dog?
- Well I'll say first of all
that I think the domestication story
is still unfolding, right,
there are still people who are trying to,
and claim to find the earliest examples of
the divergence between
the early canine ancestor
kind of wolf and dogs.
And it might've happened
in multiple places.
But it looks like at some point,
one of the best theories is
really Ray Copenger's theory
which is that dogs, or proto-dogs,
some wolves kind of self selected
right about when humans were becoming
less nomadic and having settlements.
And with any settlements
you kind of create
trash outside of your settlement.
The food that goes
uneaten, the early dumps.
And some wolves might have,
already a social species,
felt less wary of this
animal in their environment,
and approached this new food source,
a new ecological niche basically,
that we created inadvertently,
and therefore came into closer proximity
with these early humans.
And then might have started
to be taken in by us,
and maybe because some of
them were appealing to us
as puppies, maybe partly for
food, something like that,
and then artificial
selection started after that.
So this was a species,
and I wanna make clear,
it wasn't today's wolf, right,
it was some ancestor of today's wolf.
So we look at the wolf today and we think,
well the dog came from that wolf,
but of course that wolf has also evolved
over thousands of years
from this common ancestor.
Some early wolf must
have had a reduction of
reactivity to humans
and felt less fearful,
and therefore allowed for the possibility
that we could come into interaction.
And we created an environmental scenario
that encouraged the possibility
of that interaction.
And then some spark happened between us.
- And you're saying that wolves,
these ancestor wolves brought to the table
characteristics that were
useful for this transition
that helped make it possible,
and you describe the
relationship of the wolf
to his own pack,
and then the adaptation and flexibility of
the ancestor wolf in its original setting.
- Right, so wolves are social already.
They live in social groups
and these are packs,
and these are really family units.
So that's already mirroring us.
It happens with other social mammals too,
but that's already mirroring
something about us.
We're living in extended family units
and so are wolves.
And the alpha pair are really
the eldest of this family.
And so that's a very tight knit group.
They're somewhat territorial,
but extremely filiative with each other.
And so that makes them
mirror, in some way,
the kind of human social relationship
that we have now, and
that we've always had.
And so if only we could
start to see each other
as kind of con-specifics,
and they have some flexibility in that,
at least the dogs that we've selected do,
then we could interweave
in each other's families.
So they must've had some early
developmental flexibility
such that the difference
between wolves and dogs now
is that dogs have a much
longer sort of sensitive period
where they could be
exposed to other species
and view them as con-specifics,
as you know is essentially
part of their own family.
Wolves are shorter, but
there must've been some
sufficient extension in those
early self selecting wolves
so that they could come to accept a human.
- And you say in the book that
it's really a difference in
how long it takes for
the baby dog, or wolf,
to open their eyes, which then,
in the case of the dog
there's a longer period
which is a threshold or a starting point
for feeling affection for something
other than another dog, or the mother dog,
but they can extend it
to a different species.
- Right, essentially a sensitive period,
or critical period if you're talking about
some species of very
regimented, early window
for social exposure, or for hearing sounds
of other species and so forth,
it's critical period.
If it's a little bit looser
it's a sensitive period.
So some broader sensitive
window in the dog
eventually than in the wolf.
You know, Karma Lawrenz
discovered the idea,
or popularized the idea
of the critical period,
and he famously exposed himself,
I mean that in the most literal way,
not in the extended way,
but he removed some
goslings from their mother,
and he was the first
individual those goslings saw
and they imprinted on him.
So that's a kind of flexibility
that lots of animals have,
that is, whoever the
first creature is you see,
that's the one you attach
yourself to, and mimic,
and you're gonna rely on.
But it's a very brief window for geese,
so it's a broader window for some mammals.
- Now let's talk about
what's inside the dog,
its senses, its sensibility, and so on,
and what is the most important thing
that we need to know about its senses?
Which is the most important?
- I think everyone knows at some level
that the dog is an olfactory creature.
But they are entirely olfactory.
You know, it's not that they
don't have other senses,
but as we are visual creatures,
and most of our experiences at this moment
are experiences of images,
not so much smells, and not so much,
well there's hearing of
course, but not primarily,
our overarching experience is
visual, they are olfactory.
And so that's, to then
really loiter in that fact
for a while, let's sit and steep in it,
and think about what it would be like
to be an olfactory creature
who's experience of this room
would not be of the sights,
but instead of places where
smells are coming from
or smells that are here from past guests,
and passersby and so forth.
I think that's transformative,
to think of the dog that way.
So they're not the only
olfactory creature,
but they're the only one
living in our homes as it were.
And so that's manifested
in a number of ways.
You know they have many, many
more olfactory receptors,
which gives them exponentially
greater sensitivity
to the presence of any
smell than we would have.
They have a sophisticated
method of sniffing.
So just as we don't get enured
to something we're
looking at, or staring at,
they can keep smelling, inhaling,
without kind of exhaling
the smell out of their nose.
In fact, their exhales
kind of help their inhales.
You know they have this
secondary olfactory-like organ
called the vomeronasal
organ in the hard pallet
of the roof of the mouth
to allow smelling
hormones, emitted hormones,
obviously functionally adaptive
to deal with other
members of their species,
but also presumably they're
able to detent the hormones
that we're always giving
off, pheromones we call it.
So they're entirely
organized around smell,
and their vision is perfectly good.
But I think that's the thing to realize
when trying to imagine
if one is really interested in imagining
the dog's point of view,
is that when we step out onto the street
and this world just appears
for us however it appears,
their world is appearing to them
as the smells passing on the breeze,
or whatever smells underfoot,
or left on that lamp post.
- And in using the smell
strength so to speak,
they're acquiring information basically.
So what you're saying is
we need to think of it in that way
because they are learning
about their environment,
the people in the
environment through that,
and they're decoding the information.
- That's right, I think
that when we're using vision
we're getting information too, right?
And we think of smells I think,
it's hard for us to imagine
being olfactory creatures
because we assign smells a quality.
You know, it's like a
good smell or a bad smell,
or maybe their identities.
There are some people who are very good
at recognizing what the smells are,
but mostly we just kind of think
there are a set of smells we like
and a set of smells we don't like.
But we think of vision
as giving us information
about the world, this is where I am,
this is who was here,
this is what happened.
I might see some sign that
somebody was here before,
and I think that's exactly
how they're drawing
a picture of their space with olfaction.
So it's not laden with is
this a good or bad smell,
it's whose smell is that?
And what information is there in the urine
that splattered this
hydrant about the urinator,
and her health, and her sexual status,
and maybe her stress hormone level.
I don't know, I mean
they're not exactly sure
what they could experience.
But they have the capacity to pull out
all those bits of information.
And so about humans as well.
Who passed by,
hence the effectiveness of trackers who,
they don't need a foot step,
they just need somebody kind
of having sloughed our smell
in our wake as we run away
for the dog to detect that we were there
sometime in the past.
So yeah, they might even be smelling time
because the difference
between a strong odor
and a weak odor is
really when it was laid.
So a strong odor means
somebody passed more recently.
So it is entirely information, yeah.
- And you talk a little
about this whole question
whether dogs can tell whether
their companion is ill,
basically, their human companion
has a disease and so on.
- Sure, and there's no reason that the dog
wouldn't be able to smell that.
I mean any diseased cells give off
a very distinctive smell.
I mean doctors used to be trained in,
reliably trained in
the smells of diseases.
You know I think tuberculosis has
something like a brown bread smell.
So instead of just getting
a blood test from you,
a doctor might come over and just see
if you're giving off a smell
that would be informative
about you, right,
not good or bad but informative.
And so we're giving off those smells.
And we know that dogs can then detect
the changes of tissue wrought
by cancer, for instance,
because dogs are easily trained,
and many have been trained
to alert to cancerous cells
in whatever the substrate.
On a body if it's melanoma,
or in urine if it's bladder cancer
they're trying to detect,
or in breath if it's lung cancer.
So they are detecting them.
Now that doesn't mean that everybody's dog
is looking for illness
in their owner, right,
but my guess is that they might notice it.
And then if we ask them,
train them to tell us,
and we knew what their
telling us looked like,
then they could also tell us about it.
- And do they compute?
In other words, is there
evidence that they can
combine their affection for someone
with this detection of disease
to then try to alert the person?
I mean that would be different than
just smelling a bunch of people
that they don't know for disease.
- Right, so you could be training on odor,
or a component inherent
in a cancer, for instance.
And that's what the dogs who
are trained to do this do.
And so your question is
really does familiarity
breed a kind of smell understanding
such that if there's a
violation of that understanding,
a change wrought be an illness,
a dog would detect it
and be able to tell you
about it essentially.
- Because of their affection for you.
- Yeah, well I guess I
was translating affection
as familiarity, because
I'm just trying to say
well why would they be affectionate?
Because they have a relationship with you.
They're familiar presumably so, yes.
I mean the answer would be of course
they will notice the difference
if there is a difference to be noted.
But I still think it's a big,
you know then you have to
notice that they're noticing,
which is a hard thing for us to do
given that we live among dogs
and we notice very
little of their behavior,
as far as I'm concerned,
in the ordinary course.
We're not really looking
and trying to understand
what they're doing by watching them.
We're kind of putting
an understanding on them
and then assuming they live up to it.
So I don't think we would
notice their noticing.
- Interestingly, these
olfactory sensibilities,
obviously they must apply to other dogs,
not just to humans.
So this is sort of key
to their ability to play.
Choosing their playmates to the extent
that they're not chosen for them.
Is that correct?
Yeah, so this sensibility
is at work and play.
- Sure, I think in any social
interaction with other dogs,
right, in determining how if
it's a competitive scenario,
and there's food or
attention being doled out,
you could use information
about the health or age
of another dog to make a decision
about whether you're stronger,
or more likely to get that attention,
or if this is a good well
matched playmate, and so forth.
- You compare the dog
to their wolf ancestors,
and you discern a difference
in the intelligence,
or the kind of intelligence
that a dog has.
I think you say wolves are
better at working at puzzles,
whereas the dog is more
a creature that relates to
the other to get information.
Talk a little about that,
because this is a,
and I think you then
also discussed the notion
of working on objects, basically.
Talk a little about that.
How to use their senses to
deal with their environment
beyond just being an observer of it.
- There are a lot of types
of tasks that would be
put to a dog or any other animal
in a comparative psychology approach.
And there's a lot of research.
This is not my research
but research of others.
Looking at really their
physical cognition skills,
which would be kind of
the problem solving skills
for the most part,
and then social cognition skills
which would be problem solving
that involves individuals.
And so wolves and dogs put to the same
physical cognition tasks
performed quite differently,
with wolves usually surpassing dogs
if you wanna talk about
who's the better performer.
So a nice test is a kind
of impossible box task
where let's say there's a piece of rope
that's attached to meat
that's secreted inside a box,
and the animal has to
learn to pull the rope
and get the meat.
And both wolves and dogs can do this,
but then if it's impossible to open,
they pull it and can't get the box open,
it's really well fastened,
the wolf will really go at that task.
And they will figure out a way
or they will die trying, essentially,
to get inside.
They're intent on it.
And a dog, alternately,
will go at it a little bit
and then usually, typically,
the average dog if there
was such a thing, gives up.
And then they do something
very interesting,
which is the social cognitive part.
Which is to say they look to the person,
who incidentally is the one almost always
solving problems for dogs.
If my dog wants to have food,
she doesn't go forage for food
or try to discover it on her own,
she just comes to me,
and voila, I am the one who
solves that problem every time.
And so dogs seem to be very good
at using us as a kind of
tool to solve any problem.
But they're sort of failing
the physical cognition test.
So that's an interesting reason maybe
some comparative psychology methods,
and the answers you
traditionally say they give
don't work as well for dogs.
They failed the task,
but they've also really succeeded
because they've got a much better tool.
They don't have to go
at that until they die,
they can just pester the person
and the person is probably gonna
help them solve the puzzle.
And so then that's the
social cognition part,
and they perform much better than wolves.
One of the methodologies
that has for some reason
really hit it off,
and a lot of different researchers
in this field have studied,
is like dog's success at
following points, or gaze.
And they're very good at that,
much, much better than
wolves for the most part,
unless wolves have lived among humans,
and even better than chimps.
So better than our closest relatives.
And that seems so automatic, right?
You point someplace and
the dog kind of knows
that that's something there.
But a chimp when you point,
they'll look at the end of your finger,
not at the place which humans say
we're obviously intending,
that place over there on the floor,
not this thing that I'm
using as information.
And dogs seem to get this very early on
given the right development.
And so that's an interesting skill
that allows them to get
information from us.
They can follow our gaze this way,
and it also means they're looking
at our faces a lot,
which incidentally I think
is greatly implicated
in our human feelings,
that dogs really understand us,
that we're really in a
conversation together,
because guess what, they just look at us.
I think they're probably
smelling more than looking,
but they're directed toward us
just as in a conversation.
So they really succeed at
social cognitive tasks,
and the wolves are less good at that.
Probably because they're less trained at,
less driven to look at a face.
- Which they don't do, you say.
- But they don't typically do that
if they're not exposed to humans.
Eye contact, prolonged eye contact
would not be tolerated.
That's really a threat, not,
you know you wouldn't
want to go up to a wolf
and just stare at them.
The same with a dog you
don't know, for instance,
but the dog you do know,
you might just sit there
and gaze at each other,
and that really feels like it's the basis
for an understanding,
and other animals don't do that.
They use gaze as threat.
So wolves won't really look us in the face
for a long period,
they're not getting
information from our gaze
and from our points,
and so they're gonna fail at those
social cognitive tasks relative to dogs.
- So what you're describing
is a real justification
for your point of the book
which is to get into
the umwelt of the dog,
because if you were doing
intelligence testing,
you might conclude,
well the dog is a dummy.
But what you're saying is no,
you gotta look at the context which is
that they are a social animal,
whereas a wolf is really only
social within its own pack.
- Yeah, they're so social with us,
and that's their real skill.
And I think understanding
the dog's perspective there
is that the dog's social world
has extended to include the human.
And that's quite a skill.
- You look at this relationship
between humans and dogs,
and it's almost a marriage made in heaven,
so to speak,
and you talk about things that we,
the commonality that leads
us to meet each other
in this relationship.
And one is contact, right?
In other words, both humans and dogs
like to be touched, basically.
- Yeah, and I think that touch is
affiliative, it's affectionate.
And dogs kind of suffer
being touched by us.
I mean they like to be touched.
Wolves, their relations
would sleep together,
and on top of each other and so forth,
but also dogs will seem to endure
all sorts of types of touching from us.
Regardless of if we're
family members or not.
And that's very appealing.
If you looked just anthropologically,
if you watched people go by a pet store
and how they interacted
with the inhabitants
of that pet store who they'd never met,
most people wanna touch the animal, right,
that's very important for us.
And dogs will allow that,
that's part of their way of
interacting with each other.
- And there's a kind of
a mutual signaling which,
I guess you're saying the
dog originally got that
from the wolves returning to the pack.
But they've sort of crossed species
and so this whole greeting thing
is a big deal in the relationship.
- Yeah, so when a hunting dog returns
to his or her pack, and has made a kill,
they really are mobbed
by their pack members,
there is a big greeting.
And it is a greeting, it's very exciting.
And they do all this
licking around the face
of the returning hunter,
and that prompts the hunter to regurgitate
some of the food to share with everybody.
And it's so interesting
to see that same behavior
within human homes, where you have,
we return and our dog
comes and jumps at us
and licks at our face,
and it is just a greeting to us.
In fact we call it a kiss.
A dog licks your face, people
call it kissing or something.
And so that's the end
of our definition of it.
And I think it's interesting
to go back one step
and say, oh right,
usually the returning dog
would have regurgitated some
of the food to everybody.
And we rarely do that.
I don't know that the dog
would be unhappy if we did.
But so I think it is a greeting,
but you get some more knowledge
about the history of that greeting
from looking at their ancestors.
- And when this licking when you
come back from a restaurant,
they're gathering information.
I mean they're not yet ready to say,
oh you went to Che Panice for dinner
and you left me here.
But in other words, they
are absorbing information.
Is that information useful for them,
or does it just give them security
to input this information?
- Well, I mean look at it this way.
If we have information that
we've been eating something,
and the origin of this licking was
to provoke sharing of that eating,
then the smell would prompt them to do
more and more of it to
try to, as a request,
to try to get us to share it with them.
So it's informative in that way.
I don't think they put it in the bank,
"And she went out every night,
"and she had pizza five times,
"and then she had Chinese food."
But certainly it would've been
useful to get information.
Yeah, and so all the smelling.
Think of all the smells we must pick up.
Not just of other dogs as it were,
that we might've touched in the world,
but just smells that are
hitting us from the world
as we travel through our environments
which that dog's nose is sensitive to.
That's information for them about,
in some way about where we've been,
or who we've been interacting with.
And it is, I think, interesting to them.
- And finally, you emphasize the timing
of the relationship, that in other words,
which is about what?
- Well for instance, there
is a lot of turn taking.
And mutual looking, and
checking back, and looking away,
between dog and human,
which is very reminiscent of how humans
deal with each other in conversation,
there's some very nice
studies showing that
the sort of bouncing
back and forth of actions
between, or gaze between dog and human
is very similar to flirting,
mixed sex strangers
behaviors between each other.
So they're doing something
in interaction with us,
even without words,
even without the same understanding.
Which is familiar to us,
which is just appealing to us
and fits into our model of
how you deal with others.
And so we slip them right
into that category of others.
- When we started you mentioned the fact
that you were someone who had
had companionship with dogs,
I won't use the word owner.
And so I'm curious now
to look back and ask
how you, as a dog person,
has informed your science,
and how your science has
informed you as a dog person.
- Hmm.
I think living with
dogs informed my science
by changing the types of questions I ask.
I'm very interested in
the fact that we have
an entire vocabulary,
people who live with dogs
have an entire vocabulary
to describe their dogs,
you know right from very early
on living with their dogs,
these anthropomorphisms we put on the dogs
about their understanding,
and what they think, and why,
and what they think of us.
And that functions pretty well, actually.
It might not be right, it might be right,
but it just functions pretty well
for the entirety of that
dogs life with that person.
And those aren't the types of questions
that comparative psychology usually asks.
They ask, do you follow a point?
Or as I did in approach,
does the dog have a
kind of theory of mind,
or a rudimentary theory of mind?
And I think those are
interesting questions but
I've moved away from those a little bit,
and I'm asking more the types of questions
about whether those words
that we use to describe dogs
when we're living with dogs are correct,
or if there's a better explanation,
or is there something where we can get
a better understanding of the
dog by using different words.
And so I think that's
what living with dogs
has done to my science.
My science, what the science has done
with my living with dogs has I think
made me a much better owner.
And I will use that word,
it's just a convenient word,
but I don't think of myself
as owning dogs per se.
It just explains that relationship.
I've become a much better observer.
I think I've become a much better,
much more conscientious
person living with dogs,
and much more sensitive to what the
dog might need, or desire, or want,
or what the dog is telling me.
So gee, now I understand when the dog is
trying to get my attention
for something important that they need.
The very few things they ask of us, food,
or going outside, or
interaction, much earlier.
So I can kind of change the
way a dog gets your attention,
instead of having to ramp it up
until they're barking at
you, and annoying you,
you can see when they just come
and touch your knee with
their nose as a request,
and see yeah, you're
communicating with me,
I'm gonna see what you want.
That's very satisfying.
The dog is, if you're seeing
what the dog is saying,
that's very satisfying.
And I also am much more appreciative
of letting my dogs smell the world.
So we have, I describe in my book,
the smell walks we take,
where this whole predefined interaction
that we have with dogs where we're gonna
take them for a walk.
Everyone knows if you're gonna have a dog
you're have to take them for walks, right?
And mostly that's about elimination,
and maybe it's about exercise,
but lets say you're a dog who's
inside for 20 hours a day,
with maybe nobody to deal
with for most of that
because the people you
live with are working.
What would be great?
Going for a walk.
Why?
Not just so that you can urinate,
but also to see other dogs
which is very important,
I think everyone agrees on that.
But also you can smell
what the world is like.
So what if we took walks where every time
they wanted to stop and smell,
and we're pulling at
their leashes to come on,
hurry up, we have to take a walk.
You know, we realize that's their walk.
They're walking, this is
what the experience is,
and letting them enjoy that,
or experience it, whatever it is.
And I love that now.
I love seeing my dogs do that.
And letting them live out
of their noses a little bit.
So that's, and that's only since really
I started studying dogs that I did that.
I didn't know that ahead of time.
It was only through
reflecting on their capacity
that I realized I should change
my way of walking my dog.
- Well one of the themes in this book,
and in your new book on, I can't remember,
On Looking, is you have a very strong
interest in attention, right?
I think you say in that second book
that our environment really
makes us unattentive,
and part of what you're interested in
is how do we re-aim that
attention, and so on.
Talk a little about that
because it's clearly a theme
in the focus that you have on cognition.
- Yeah, I think you're right.
And I wouldn't, in cognition
attention is a whole specialty.
And I never was drawn to that.
So I think it's a different
type of meaning of attention.
Now that you mention it,
what it is is an interest in
looking in a different way
at something which is familiar.
You know in some sense that
is a connection between
my recent writing and my
research in writing about dogs,
is there is a very familiar thing.
We already know about it.
You know maybe some people didn't,
psychology didn't even think that the dog
was worth studying cognitively,
as we already know.
And now here's an ordinary
block in the city,
which is a walk I took again
and again for On Looking.
We already know what's on the walk,
so we don't need to look.
And so we've lost a type of attention
to object or scene which
actually has a lot of levels
of richness that we could notice.
As opposed to being attracted
to the exotic, I think,
I'm kind of attracted to getting
different perspectives on the ordinary.
And so that's the attention
I'm interested in bringing,
like a new way of looking
at something familiar.
- And so dogs were a good
field of study for you.
- I think so, accidentally.
- Because you say they're anthropologists
of us in their world.
- Yeah right, and they'll looking at us
in an interesting way.
I really admire how well they look at us
and observe our behavior.
- Well, Alexandra this
has been a fascinating
conversion, let me show your book again,
'cause I think it's a great read,
and people are gonna want to
come to it for that reason
but also because of
their interest in dogs.
Thank you very much for
coming on our program.
- Thanks Harry.
- Thank you.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat techno music)